♪ ♪
>> Laura: LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI HAS A PLAN THAT HE
SAYS WILL HELP SOLVE RACISM IN
AMERICA.
WELL, IT REQUIRES UP TO
$150 MILLION FROM THE POLICE
BUDGET AND PUTTING IT TOWARDS
MORE SOCIAL WELFARE AND JOBS
PROGRAMS IN BLACK COMMUNITIES.
GARCETTI ALSO SAID THAT FAILURE
TO ENACT HIS GRAND DESIGN WOULD
MEAN "WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
BEING THE KILLERS THAT WE ARE."
BY NEXT GUEST, JAMIE McBRIDE,
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVELY IS JUST
IRATE ABOUT THAT SMEAR, WATCH.
>> CLEARLY UNSTABLE.
HE’S MORE INTERESTED IN HIS
IMAGE AS OPPOSED TO BEING A
LEADER DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES.
YESTERDAY HE SMEARED EVERY
SINGLE POLICE OFFICER IN
LOS ANGELES AND ACROSS THE
NATION BY CALLING US KILLERS.
THAT’S OFFENSIVE, IT’S WRONG AND
DESPICABLE.
>> Laura: MR. McBRIDE JOINS
ME NOW.
JAMIE, MAYOR GARCETTI SAID YOU
WERE TAKING HIS REMARKS OUT OF
CONTEXT.
AND THAT BY KILLERS HE MEANT OUR
COLLECTIVE BURDEN ON SOCIETY,
WHATEVER THE HECK THAT MEANS.
WHAT’S YOUR FURTHER RESPONSE TO
HIS EXPLANATION?
>> I THINK IT’S QUITE CLEAR WHAT
HE MEANT.
HE ACTUALLY CORRECTED IT AND
SAID HE DIDN’T MEAN L.A.P.D.,
HE’S SAID OFFICERS ACROSS THE
NATION, WHICH I THINK IS EVEN
WORSE.
ERIC GARCETTI HAD SECURITY
DETAIL ON HIS RESIDENCE TO GUARD
HIS FAMILY 24/7, HIS CHILDREN,
SO HE HAS KILLERS GUARDING HIS
CHILDREN.
THAT’S HOW RIDICULOUS THIS THING
IS.
WE HAVE OFFICERS THAT WERE
INJURED THE LAST WEEK AND A
HALF, ONE WAS SHOT.
WE HAD OFFICERS THAT HAD THEIR
HEADS FRACTURED, THEIR SKULLS
FRACTURED, THEY ARE IN THE
HOSPITAL IN ONE MINUTE LITERALLY
HE’S PRAISING US FOR OUR
DEDICATION AND SERVICE, TWO DAYS
LATER HE’S CALLING US KILLERS
AND THERE’S SOMETHING DEFINITELY
WRONG WITH ERIC GARCETTI.
HE HAS FAILED A LEADERSHIP TEST.
HE HAS DEFINITELY UNSTABLE AND I
THINK HE NEEDS TO STEP BACK AND
DO A SELF REFLECT, HE JUST CAN’T
HANDLE THE STRESS OF A BIG CITY
LIKE LOS ANGELES.
>> Laura: WELL, HE’S FOCUSED
ON CHASING PEOPLE OFF BEACHES
APPARENTLY.
THAT’S EASIER DUTY FOR HIM.
CONGRESSMAN KAREN BASS WANTS TO
DO WITH THE MONEY, JAMIE, THAT
WOULD BE CUT UNDER THIS PLAN
FROM THE POLICE BUDGET.
WATCH.
>> PART OF THAT CRY IS A DESIRE
FOR THERE TO BE SIGNIFICANT
HIGHER INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES.
LOOKING AT WHY POLICE ARE
NEEDED, WHAT HAPPENS, WHAT ARE
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE PROBLEMS
IN COMMUNITIES AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE FEEL WHEN IT COMES TO
DEFENSE BUDGETS, MAYBE THAT
MONEY COULD BE USED IN DIFFERENT
WAYS.
>> Laura: JAMIE, SOUNDS
REASONABLE?
>> FOR ONE THING, YOU CAN’T CUT
THE POLICE BUDGET.
THERE’S TOO MANY THINGS THAT ARE
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE RIOTS THAT WE EXPERIENCED
THE LAST TWO WEEKS, THAT’S GOING
TO BE AN EVERYDAY OCCURRENCE,
IT’S GOING TO BE LIKE A CURTAIN
RUSSELL MOVIE ESCAPE FROM
LOS ANGELES.
IF YOU CUT THE BUDGET YOU’RE
GOING TO HAVE A SLOWER RESPONSE
TIME, THE RESPONSE TO 911 CALLS
BECAUSE HE WILL HAVE FEWER
OFFICERS ON THE STREET.
IF YOU CUT THE BUDGET YOU’RE
GOING TO HAVE A SLOWER
INVESTIGATIONS.
TALK ABOUT REFORM.
WHERE THE NUMBER ONE AGENCY WHEN
IT COMES TO REFORM.
PART OF BEING REFORMED IS YOU
GOT TO HAVE TRAINING AND IN
ORDER TO HAVE TRAINING WE HAVE
TO HAVE A BUDGET TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE WITHIN THE REFORMING
THAT THEY WANT US TO BE IN.
LET’S GO A LITTLE BIT STEP
FURTHER, LAURA.
A COUPLE YEARS AHEAD NOW.
HE WANTS TO CUT THE BUDGET,
WHAT’S COMING AROUND THE CORNER
FOR LOS ANGELES?
THE WORLD CUP AND BEYOND THAT,
THE OLYMPICS.
IN 1981 THEY HAD A MASS HIRING
FOR POLICE OFFICERS GEARING UP
FOR THE ’83 LIMBIC’S.
IF HE CUTS THE BUDGET WE ARE
GOING TO BE SO FAR BEHIND, I
DON’T THINK IT WOULD BE SAVIOR
OF THE WORLD CUP HERE, I DON’T
THINK IT WOULD BE SAFE TO HAVE
THE OLYMPICS HERE.
>> Laura: I REMEMBER THE
OLYMPICS, I WAS THERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SUMMER.
THAT WAS FUN, BUT ALL I CAN SAY
IS, GIVEN WHAT I SAW IN THE
FOOTAGE IN SANTA MONICA THAT THE
MAINSTREAM NETWORKS DIDN’T PLAY,
IF YOU MISS THAT FOOTAGE OF WHAT
WAS BEING DONE TO THOSE
BUSINESSES AND THOSE INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS,
SEARCH AROUND, YOU HAVE TO BE
YOUR OWN INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
TO FIND IT, BUT JAMIE, WE’RE
GOING TO FOLLOW THIS, KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH US PLEASE, WE ARE